virtual is known for its changing news
on sanchong mutant our intention is to
reconnect the people with the mountain
and the mountain back to the city Fatah
was first set up as people orientated
urban design project in photo stretching
the full breadth of Jimmy Olsen Jimmy
Olsen is a hinterland in the city and
the whole design is to meet this part of
the hinterland and love is potential not
only it provides easy access to the
green land to the city but it also add
resilience and livability
to the community and at the same time it
also has 10 entrances which we call as
notes to revitalize and to reenergize
the surrounding areas for example in
this Sports Complex
we created a four-story high spiral ramp
which is a height modulator to bring
people prickly up to the mountain and
indirectly the building becomes the told
law and people are able to relate to it
as part of the small mountain the main
part of this particular project is
endeavour to bring not only abled body
but also less stable body to the
inaccessible mountain the what way is
designed with a very gentle gradient so
that people on wheelchair or baby on
stroller can transverse in a very
comfortable way in our own design
philosophy as we live in a very dense of
the
the need to get close to nature and to
enable people from all walks of life to
be able to gain a sense to this natural
environment it is important it is to
help to build resilience to increase the
livability of the Evangelos